number six is interesting bleach
thousand year blood warock yeah so I'm
probably the only one that's watched
this I've seen the first four EP does my
anime list always do this does it always
write it in the Japanese way in the
English Japanese way I I guess so yeah
that's kind of weird why why would they
not just call thousand blood AR on the
because that's what it's actually called
it's just dumb though you're talking
about the uh the website that won't
allow Scott Pilgrim to be listed as an
anime even though it was made in Japan
they like they like it's like I don't
know to me I I've got R now but I seems
so [__] dumb just why just put an
attack on Titan if if they gave this
name for it in English officially why
are we not using just call a thousand
year blood does anyone really need it to
be it's like on Twitter when people go
like boano hero Academia it's like bro
just call my hero Academia it's
literally in the title it's title is my
hero and I love how they get like
nitpicky with it as all like they'll
they'll say that about certain shows and
then they'll be like I'm not calling
Full Metal
Alchemist like I'm calling it full metal
yeah it is it is very frustrating this
is double standard with they're like I
want to seem like I'm really in touch
with it and it's like shut shut the [__]
up it's it's called they gave it blood
bleach thousand year [__] [__]
let's call it that s okay so I've only
ever I've seen the first four episodes
so I can't speak on how good the entire
show is I mean you have right yeah I
mean there's not much to say about it it
just goes hard I mean I say this is not
even a fan of bleach the action scenes
go I've seen super [__] hard this is
like movie level this is like movie
level animation in 13 episodes oh yeah
we hanging out with our friend he was
like you have to watch this I was like
I'm not going to watch it he pulls out
his phone starts showing I'm like yeah
that looks [__] cool but I yeah like
can you watch this without
watching that's that's the that's the
problem when and I think that's why the
last AR right yeah this is the last AR
and that's why I think this score is so
high up
because the only bleach fans would have
gotten this far into the story because
this is like the The Last Arc after
about hundreds of episodes in um the
animation out of nowhere just leveled up
to a point where it's some of the best
action animation you could ask for is it
also true that they slightly changed uh
some parts of the story in the anime
version I heard that Kubo has been more
involved uh this is all speculation so
I'm not too sure but that might be um
but I don't really yeah like I said I
don't really have much to say about it
aside from if you're a bleach fan this
is going to be orgasmic and I do
understand why this said I want to see
some B godamn it and they got it number
six but is not number six it's not
number six is it even top 50 bleach as a
series no it's such a decisive I I like
G say the crazy [__] so then I'm like
yeah what
he I I liked a lot of bleach I disliked
a lot of bleach um what would you what
would you give bleach
overall okay here's the hard thing about
rating never seen bleach by the way yeah
here's okay here's the hard thing about
rating any Shonen Jump show right which
is I don't think it's fair to rate
Shonen Jump shows based on an entire
let's say the entire run right because I
think I think it's more easier to rate
sh and jump shows on arcs yeah I could
rate the arcs because arcs are so vastly
different and the thing that makes it
hard to review a Shonen Jump show in its
entirety is because of the way sh jump
is structured right ideas and focus can
often shift where shows can feel
completely different and unlike
something like on tack on Tyson where it
seemed like completely planned sometimes
it can feel like it's just keeps going
on and it keeps escalating for the sole
reason of it being shown and jump like
the my best example of this is Naruto
right where um where you look at the you
look at the power scaling and you look
at the fights at the beginning of the
series and you compare it to the end of
the series and they almost feel like two
completely different
where you look at something like Attack
on Titan where you know not even sh J
but I'm just using that as an example
where Titans got less threatening but it
didn't feel like it was because it got
power scaled it felt like because the
more we leared about Titans The More
Humans learned how to combat them so
they were still a threat by the end of
the series but they felt like less of a
threat compared to the beginning series
and that felt like a more natural
progression but would you say bleach is
in that same vein because when I compare
say the soul Society Arc right the first
Arc to the Thousand-Year blood War Arc I
don't really see that big of a jump in
that sense of like it feeling like two
completely different shows right like
there's obviously a lot happened in
between that time and there were a lot
of great arcs lot of [__] arcs but I
think overall the Thousand Year blood
War Arc still felt like bleach if that
makes sense okay so I got to ask you
guys when you read a long running or
long running show do you sometimes get
this point where you kind of like
mentally check out but you you keep you
keep like every everyone has this like
some people a lot of people have this
point when they kind of like they keep
reading but they kind of like mentally
check out yeah you're like I'm I'm
reading this out of obligation yeah yeah
I was honestly kind of like that when I
was reading warm punchman manga I just
kind of checked out after a while but
then it got super hype again I was like
I'm back
in just when I thought I was out they
pull me back in yeah I kind of like
checked out a little bit but then I was
like all right I [__] I'm back to me
like I I kind of like checked out
bleach Midway through the not what was
what was the arc that went on for
[__] ages wo uh not wo I think it was
like at the end of wundo where I was
like I am happy with you know I'm happy
with everything that I've read yeah and
then I was like I'm going to keep
reading until they defeat eizen and then
the series is going to be over and then
they defeated eizen and I'm like
it's still going yeah all right I'll
check it out for one more Arc all right
it still keeps going and I kind of
checked out halfway through the espart
arc as well I just like come on okay I
get it just where I where I was where I
was just like okay I thought it was
going to be over I thought it did and
they just like kept going and kept going
and this was the last Arc where I kind
of like they they pulled me back in a
little bit just because I knew it was
The Last Arc uh and they pull me back in
just because you know the the action did
go [__] hard and some massive things
happened um but like at this point I I
was kind of like just reading bleach
just to see the end of bleach because I
want to see the end of bleach um and to
me
bleach bleach just went on for too long
to me that's my opinion yeah I mean I
read all the Bleach Manga but I kind of
half did it just to like close the book
on this chapter of my life to be like
this has been with me a long time in my
life and I'm glad it's over am I
satisfied with it not necessarily but at
least I can say that I have finished it
you know it's done I would have to like
I know bleach fans are very very
passionate uh I can't wait for comments
and I I will have to like I would have
to like reread bleach just to give my
proper let's say proper opinion on it uh
just because it's been such a long
[__] time since I've read Bleach uh
so I don't I G in my memory of bleach is
very fragmented cuz it was kind of
stretched out in a long period of time
obviously so don't take anything we say
seriously but six n yeah six but six n n
uh G of the final great movie let's move
on hun Hunter 2011 yes yes okay so I've
only read the Manga so I can't comment
on the anime like my favorite anime I
think I've ever watched overall I think
I get the hype now
that Hunter Hunter anime was the most
engaged and like most like I I literally
couldn't sleep CU I had to watch the
next episodes uh it was I just loved it
I everything about hun Hunter I loved so
much I love the world so so much oh the
World building is incredible yeah and
the and this anime was amazing I thought
it did a really good job and I you know
uh some some of the pacing in the very
very start is a little slow but it
really picks up right away and then just
never drops never let you go I know a
lot people say the Anar is too long but
I really like the Anar I like the Kim an
AR I [__] love it yeah yeah I think
the difference between something like
the cimera antar and some arcs like when
I think when I think of that dragged I
think of like Naruto arcs which is like
the fourth ninja raw Arc where I'm like
this was cool and then it kind of like
went on a bit too long Aaron car Arc as
well in Bleach the cimara ant Arc I feel
like there were so many like it it was
very long but there were so many insane
developments and insane ideas presented
in this one single Arc uh that I feel it
justifies just how [__] long it is
yeah and I love n nen is a system I
really [__] with I think it's like my
favorite battle system uh in any show
most definitely I feel like the it like
nothing feels I like that it's not this
guy's more powerful this guy's nen
ability is just so good against all of
these things but he can get [__] up by
this other guy yeah if he's around yeah
even the most like powerful characters
have certain weaknesses which the
characters just need to figure out yeah
you I'll tell you one of my favorite
guys uh in hun Hunter why like I feel
like then that was when nen as a power
system was like really [__] so to me
and it was actually in the Chan Arc but
was like the smoke guy remember do you
remember the smoke guy the guy with the
pipe he has like three fights three or
four fights right and he wins them all
and I was like surely there's a fight
that someone is like going to top him
because he goes up against different
abilities and I just found it so [__]
cool that he was like that is that he
could make like areas out of smoke right
am I crazy Am I Wrong uh yeah he can
kind of create like Arena or like
enclosed spes in smoke or something one
of them was like water right no no no he
he went up against someone who could
create a water and his his ability was
so versatile that he could basically
find a way to get around whatever other
ability that the other guy has the
problem with remembering hter Hunter
characters there's [__] so many of
them I'm just like yeah I think I
remember that guy but it showed that
with experience bring it up bring it up
smoke guy hunter hunter smoke guy H
smoke guy hun Hunter it showed that with
experience you could like you could
figure out how to beat another guy yeah
I remember this guy yeah he was sick I
love this guy and and I just love that
it showed him in three or four different
completely different fights and he was
able to with logic deduce how to defeat
the other person with with the power
system of then and I thought that was
like so [__] cool and so [__]
insane it was also just it was really
refreshing to see a show that that said
hey my world is cool enough I don't need
to have you be attached to every single
character and follow one point of view
I'm willing to show you a bunch of this
world get you hooked on the world
instead of the characters but then you
get hooked on the characters as well and
then suddenly you have like 50
characters that you really [__] like
enjoy watching and whenever any of them
are on screen you're like oh [__] yeah I
think that's the most brilliant thing
about Hunter Hond storytelling and how
Togashi goes about the World building
thing is that like it really does feel
like even if there are certain Arc or
certain elements of the arc or like even
entire arcs where like you never see the
character
it feels like the of your mind you still
remember them and you're like I wonder
how he's doing or wonder how she's doing
and you know you want to know and and
that's I think that's what makes it so
hype when that character finally appears
and you're like oh [__] he was here this
whole time that's sick you know I even
it's like its weakest arcs I think are
better than most Shen arcs in general oh
definely definitely I don't know it was
just such a good show and I I'm the only
thing that holds it back is that it's
it's never going to be finished well
yeah well it's it's I mean he's making
progress of it his finished he's making
progress we'll see Morel sometime in the
dark the problem is is that yeah that
they the mango is introducing this thing
that says by the way this show is like
50 times bigger than you think you've
been on a tiny Island this whole time
I'm reading it now and the boat the boat
to there is so long there's a whole arc
on the boat to the new place and it's
[__] long this just never getting
finished yeah unless you has some kind
of Giga brain
uh turn back SE urn on the whole I'm
going to be completely honest remember
what I talked about earlier I think I've
mentally checked out of Hunter hun no
well okay see this is why I'm scared
this is why I didn't want to start the
manga for the longest time because I
don't want to get to that point I don't
want to get to the point where I'm
waiting so and look I totally get it
Togashi needs to take care of himself
obviously he has own issues it's fine
I'll tell you the because I do like the
idea of like the dark continent that
seems really cool but the exact moment
yeah the it's too ambitious which is
thing the exact moment was in the manga
there is a climactic fight between two
characters that have been built up and
then I read that and I was just like I
think that's it I think I'm satisfied
I've seen enough now I've seen basically
everything I think I know the what I'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I was like okay this fight has
happened uh everything with the Dark
Continent sounds cool but uh mentally I
don't even know where this is going to
go or when it's going to get to a point
point that I'm going to get like pulled
back in is this a Togashi ISM cuz I felt
the exact same way with you HW show as
well which which point was it with you
when after the Togo brother fight no
yeah because no what no I don't know
what he's saying but no I I I obviously
read it till the end but like I I think
I mentioned this in a previous podcast
episode but like I just don't really I I
feel you H show kind of fizzled out and
that was just something like your chap
to Black was like the best AR of you
haak show no chapter black is the best
AR of you haaka show it was it was it
had so many insane ideas and one of the
best villain in it had so many insane
ideas and then just Togashi just got
bored of you H was like I'm going to
Rite hun Hunter instead yeah he he does
cook too hard sometimes like he had so
many potentially cool ideas and he
delivered on some of them and then it
was just like I'm done yeah this this
this current Arc that Hunter hunters in
in the manga actually kind of pissed me
off cuz I was like what the [__] why are
we spending so much time on this on the
boat over there this feels ridiculous
it's so long I feel like I'm in berserk
again like but like but like that's
that's long cuz he just didn't release
any this one is long cuz it's [__]
long it's so long and he's not really
see so yeah it's like I don't know for
all but what you think Hunter Hunter
deserve to be top 10 honestly yeah 100%
I think I think we can all agree Hunter
Hunter when it's at its peak I think
it's unrivaled shown in I think sure it
just it has absolute faith in its world
and and it knows it I'm so glad I can
finally be involved in this hun Hunter
conversation it's it's it's not a hot
take to say hunter hunter has the best
power system in Shonen in my opinion but
I I do feel that what sets it a League
Beyond was when nen was introduced and
when that concept was introduced and it
made like you it made every fight so
compelling and it made everything so
much cooler as well it made you care
enough to know and want to go into the
details you know which Togashi does a
lot of it's It's a power system which I
think was genius because no matter how
powerful character is it always felt
like there was a counter to it and you
know with there was you know we have St
and JoJo but St and JoJo conceptually it
just it got to a point where you
couldn't really [__] comprehend what
the [__] was going on you know yeah it
was it was Iraqi just like pulling a
band name out of a hat and he was just
like I'll give this guy shrinking
abilities yeah yeah to me Hunter Hunter
its power system still conceptually
makes sense whereas with JoJo there are
some poers where I'm just like why I
like Jo it's just sick as [__] it's sick
it's sick it's just sick sometimes you
just need a [__] Physics degree to
get on to like understand what the [__]
is going on but it's still hunt Hunter
still makes I think hunt Hunter easily
is in my like top five anime of all time
I think it's just such a good Shonen if
you like Shonen and you haven't watched
it do yourself favor and do it cuz it's
it's the goat